I loved all the answers when you get
however let me just say two things I'm
one those are the people who are talked
to so far huh have says he's my other
kind of think it's wrong which is
interesting isn't it so we can arrive at
something and still look at it we'll
lock them in okay and one of the reasons
why you're looking at and thinking your
eyes don't on data is because the
numbers don't look very nice do they
they don't Center you saw this one
there's some like war but it is clearly
designed by the math teacher everything
just kind of fell out really nice okay
whereas this one doesn't okay
I want to push on this question I want
you to give me a reason why no working
done you can look at this question and
know something's going to be messy there
are gonna need numbers it's going to be
messy numbers suggest okay so remember I
said for example then I said grouping
right when you hover over this you
clearly gonna have to go through a
formula here right now why is it though
how can you know no working required the
formulas where you have to go yeah
7:17 Church i7 did you know most common
number four being asked what's your
favorite number
what's your favorite number is huge
portion of people stay seven hey people
like it but its prime okay now why is it
a problem that it's a prime in this
question five prime as well xi prime as
well why don't they call it any problem
because say for the eleven right what
did we do with that living what digital
brain do with the eleven it's added
numbers the adenoma sticking alone you
can add numbers to give whatever you
want prime consciousness let me do while
you were doing something different with
this double issues what did you do with
those 24 you were looking for factors
and seven doesn't have very many of them
not hold on anyway so you know you're
going to go to court right formula the
fact that you see something read like
that should actually make you feel
comfortable because answer is probably a
monogamous now most of you have already
gone ahead and you've taken this thing
and you've gotten a pair of numbers at
the end what pair of numbers of you go
maybe five plus the line [ __ ] - what
353 divided black it sure does look like
we've done something wrong doesn't it
okay but you've done it right that's
what you get out if you put this into
the quadratic formula so am I done
is that the answer okay so the first
thing I thought is where it's not any
etat decided to edit because actually
this and this okay so at least I can see
that this two numbers is that the answer
now remember I said when I wrote down to
Teddy
what does factorization mean it means
you've given me something and I want you
to write it as a product of two 250 yes
the results
Kizer something right and a product of
two different things two or three
different things right products right
Club in this product no and it should
make the product what would that be with
that give you the thing is styling is
kind of missing an important area right
like like they excellent right now we
have not we have not factorized at all
what have you done
hmm that's interesting because I don't
know anything about the value of x
remember what the very first starter
review question I gave you was I gave my
contrition right all of it like three
things like that right what's deny your
name and the answer is whatever you want
it to be okay
and I've chose like negative five or
something like that okay that does it
has a value it can be anything extra man
has a somewhat it ah ah can you say that
again Cheyenne sit everyone can hear
okay so this thing is in it it's not an
equation right what is it if an
expression long equation because it's
not equal to anything right now what
you've all done is you have sold this
equation you solve this equation and
that is one of these numbers in a second
have you factorized no root you haven't
done anything to do it satirizing right
okay so being that this is not everyone
how am I going to use these numbers yes
well I mean you don't have to but if you
want to ride outside we're probably
going to happen
hmm okay let's put let's rewind a second
I'll come back to this guy's connection
this guy no one use the quadratic
formula to this and good call you didn't
need you okay but if you have what would
be asked is happy this one that
interesting not the answer to the fact
that we're not sure okay
the of the for a knife the other for a
nine because you can connect formula and
satirizing are two ways of getting to
constants right that's one of the
reasons why we do this okay so is it
equally right that means at x equals
zero to those foreign i will work okay
so the quadratic formula would have
given us that so if you accidentally
done the quadratic formula and then you
realize I didn't need to do that but
finally finished off and you've got that
how would you turn that into this what
have you done if what a factorization is
X take away one of your solutions climbs
at soak away your other solutions that's
it that's the factorization so let's
write this messy guy T is equal to X
take away that
that's a lot of negatives if I'm doing
it right in my head I think you'll end
up with that feel great put it again
convinced a lot okay there's one half is
one of the factors where is the other
matter whether it's going to be X take
away the other solution right which is
disgusting
watch out for the sign into this
do you rate
it's pretty open about I think it's also
fun what do you think are you convinced
now I'm just going to leave it there so
now I'm not actually really worried
opposing the trick numbers or not what
I'm really interested in is do you
factorize I wonder you got here and then
were like I don't know what to do which
suggests to me you have practiced a lot
of these simple things okay but didn't
really know what this was because that
leads you somewhere else okay welcome to
year 11 we don't treat you like these
anymore
get yourself many people okay